this is not a wakeup call to the people
of Arizona and America that what's
happening in Israel this attack from
terrorists won't happen here then people
got to pull their head out from the S
because we have seen thousands of
Crossings you just showed some of the
figures illegal immigrants ties to these
terrorist countries and it's not a
matter of of if it happens it's when it
happens it's a national security
risk and that is Arizona Senate
candidate Carrie lake with me last
weekend on this program on impact of
Biden's Southern border policy on
National Security sources within Customs
and Border Protection telling Fox News
that in the first 14 days of the new
fiscal year border patrol has
apprehended more than 30 Iranians nearly
60 syrians 35 pakistanis over 100
Russians 285 Afghans and nearly 2,000
Chinese migrants all military age men at
the southern border joining me right now
is Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton and
Iowa Attorney General Bren bird uh good
to see you AGS thank you for being here
just yesterday we learned that nearly
2.5 million people illegally cross the
border for the just completed fiscal
year that's the highest number we've
ever seen on record Ken Paxton what has
been the impact as we know 7 million
people have come into America illegally
on Joe Biden's
watch well it's taken a huge economic
impact on us we've spent billions of
dollars trying to defend our border we
spent millions of dollars on Education
Health Care crime is is increased
dramatically as a result and of course
many many of our children are dying from
fentanyl overdoses because The Border's
wide open so it's having a dramatic
impact on my state I know that this is
not staying in Texas this is this is
going to impact the entire country for
not just years I think decades to come
this is incredible Brena bird way in
here and give us a sense of what you as
an AG can do about it Ken Paxton I know
you're about about
to uh put more lawsuits pushing back
against this federal government you've
been suing the administration Brena what
can you
do yeah well we join together and uh
work with other AGS to hold the Biden
Administration accountable by suing them
and they need to fulfill their
constitutional duty to secure the border
and if they won't do it uh we will take
them to court and uh you know here in
Iowa we're a long ways from the southern
border but the impacts are felt here
every State's a border state now because
of the absolute failure of the Biden
Administration to secure our
border uh you just last week endorsed
former president Trump obviously as soon
as Joe Biden came into the Oval Office
he reversed all of the Trump policies at
the border uh your thoughts on the
likelihood that Trump gets in and
reverses this
again well I I endorse president Trump
because he's going to fire Joe Biden and
win our country back and and he will
secure the Border we know that he did
that as President we desperately need
that uh because we're going to pay for
Biden's border failures for a long time
whether it's the drug cartels the human
trafficking the crime or the terrorists
that are crossing the southern border
president Trump is going to keep us
safe uh what do you think Ken Paxton in
terms of what you can actually do in
Texas as the
AG well look we're limited to some
degree by a US Supreme Court decision
we're hoping that as my legislature is
trying to pass a a bill that would allow
us to arrest people that were coming
into our country illegal coming into our
state that will have an opportunity to
challenge that Supreme Court decision so
that states are not left on the
sidelines as the federal government
doesn't enforce their own laws and then
tells us we can't enforce laws to
protect our citizens so I'm hopeful that
as as we move through the next couple of
months we'll have the opportunity to
challenge that law and defend our own
borders and defend our people from the
consequences of what what the Biden
Administration is doing right now who
hears those lawsuits can tell us the
process in terms of how this plays out
and how
long so it it's unfortunately I wish it
was a fast process but typically we'll
file our lawsuit in a federal district
court somewhere in Texas uh we've been
very successful at winning those cases
uh I think we've won over 70% of our
cases against the Biden Administration
and then typically when they lose it's
appealed to the fifth circuit and then
whoever loses that appeals to the US
Supreme Court several of our cases have
gone up there we've been successful on
some not on others but I'm really
hopeful about this potential case in the
future where we can have the opportunity
to protect our own citizens when the
federal government won't do it yeah and
and Brena you've said that you believe
Trump is going to win the Iowa caucuses
what about all of these lawsuits that
he's facing he's got four indictments
that he's dealing with right now how do
you see that playing out and and how can
can you say with confidence that he'll
win the Iowa caucuses given the barriers
that they've put in front of him with
these
indictments well I he is very popular in
Iowa because people remember what it was
like when Donald Trump was President
they were better off our border was
safer he fought for Farmers he's very
popular here in Iowa as far as the the
rest of it you know as a prosecutor I
believe that politics has no place in
prosecution and when I'm seeing uh what
Isen happening with politically
motivated prosecutions against President
trump it uh breaks my heart as a
prosecutor to see that because politics
belongs at The Ballot Box not uh not in
front of a criminal indictment in front
of a jury that's wrong uh and it breaks
down the rule of law in our country I
don't like to see that it's not right
well I know that these indictments will
play out over time but they'd like to
have a trial before actually the
election do you think that's uh you
think that's possible we lost our if I
think that we have to look at the
motivations there the whole motivations
for those cases they are all politically
based if he wasn't running for president
again I don't think he'd be indicted at
all uh so I commend uh president Trump
for for fighting back and fighting
through all of this it's not right for
the criminal legal process to be used as
a political weapon that is wrong it will
hurt our country and break down the rule
of law final word Ken
Paxton
look this is a a huge problem for our
our state our our country I I'm very
encouraged by the fact that Donald
Trump's doing so well in the polls I
hope that we can get a president like
him and we can go back to policies and
laws that are being enforced that will
protect my state and the rest of the
country and I'm very hopeful that that
can happen all right we'll be watching
good to have you both thanks very much
Ken Paxton and Brena bird are joining us
thank you so much hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now